[Music]
let's do it
the threat of death and destruction is
so close when you're just 30 kilometers
from the Russian border Ukrainian forces
reclaim this region in the Northeast but
there's no trophy just a ravaged
landscape a constant reminder the
Russians could return
[Music]
nine months into the Russian invasion
Ukrainian soldiers know what they need
to quickly get in and out of hot zones
in the early months of the war the
equipment wasn't great pickup trucks
SUVs and eventually captured Russian
tanks but now they have a much better
option a new high-tech armored vehicle
named the senator which passes the only
test that matters here don't know any
cases when someone from my friends or
Ukrainian soldiers was killed uh in this
car so it means that it is a provide
high quality protection for soldiers you
might be surprised to learn where the
senator was not only designed but built
in a nondescript building in a
manufacturing neighborhood near
Toronto's Pearson Airport
foreign
[Music]
that's the first stage starting from the
engineering
the company is called Rochelle the
brainchild and given name of Roman
shimanov he started the company six
years ago growing it to the point where
they're now opening another facility to
meet demand
and they've done it by relying on few
outside vendors they start with a
stripped down frame of a Ford F-550 and
then build it up from there it's
important to say that the percentage of
the Canadian content in our vehicle is
higher than any other vehicle and the
whole process that we're doing here
including the engineering they are
indeed the metal fabrication Milling
Machining turning sewing paintings
sandblasting everything is done here
in-house
extraordinary for any Canadian company
particularly so during a supply chain
crisis but that has allowed Rochelle to
increase production tenfold in the last
year alone so here you can see the
vehicles in different stages over here
you can see how people grinding and this
vehicle will be ready for paint today
every day as I mentioned we need to
prepare two vehicles a lot of pressure
that you've put on yourself people that
were delivering those vehicles to are
under much more pressure than us to date
Canada has bought eight Senators NATO
and European allies have bought at least
19 more that have already been deployed
to Ukraine with over a hundred more
still to be delivered the senator was
designed to protect its occupants that's
fairly obvious
still we brought its armored plating in
reinforced glass to a gun range to test
them out
so this would be the SKS
this is the more common round that the
forces in Ukraine would be facing
there we go
and the metal
foreign holds up nicely the 7.62
millimeter rounds did as well as
expected that hasn't done a thing
that hasn't done any damage but we were
less sure about the glass because
nothing is completely Bulletproof
so the 223 the SKS and the handgun
doesn't look like it went through and it
didn't all it did was spider web
and shatter the glass did its job really
well
yeah that's actually smooth
you're not even gonna get a glass Shard
from that
shimanov is constantly taking input from
the Ukrainian military refining the
engineering and design down to the
smallest detail to improve the Senator's
performance in a war zone it's an
intimidating vehicle was it designed
that way I guess so you don't want your
vehicle to look like a vehicle for
clowns you want an intimidating vehicle
right but it's not just about the metal
another vital aspect for ukrainians
technology that allows the soldiers
inside the vehicle to identify the
direction and caliber of bullets being
fired at them there's something
empowering about driving this
you know what I mean absolutely it's
empowering even more
when you have an armored vehicle in a
danger zone soldiers they get an armored
vehicle imagine what it does for them
they aren't designed to be combat
vehicles but the Ukrainian military uses
Senators for everything from medical
evacuations and prisoner swaps to shock
assaults and they have been hit just
moments after Russian missiles landed a
meter away this video shows the
Senator's ballistic glass and steel held
up the Ukrainian military reported no
injuries
that sort of feedback has prompted
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
to ask Canada for more armored vehicles
Canada does have some capability in this
area
Ottawa also bought 39 late armored
vehicles made in London Ontario by
military defense giant General Dynamics
those are on route to Ukraine
meanwhile Rochelle can make and deliver
a senator to the Ukraine military in a
month it's enough for defense minister
Anita Anand to suggest Canada is
perfectly positioned to be a major
player I've asked
my colleagues across the NATO alliance
to think about Canada as a leader in
this area because what we are providing
to Ukraine are brand new vehicles fresh
off the line to make sure that Ukraine
has Best in Class technology if Canada
wants to help Ukraine on the scale it's
asking for the industry needs a lot more
support says procurement expert David
Perry ukrainians are basically looking
to get their hands on as absolute much
equipment as they can there's definitely
the potential here but if you were to
assume that that was say several
thousand vehicles I don't think that
there's many company in the world that
can basically just snap their fingers
and start tooling out number of vehicles
on in only a few months time but
Rochelle isn't waiting for the
government to step in they're projecting
to make another 1 000 armored vehicles
in 2023 and to do that the company has a
secret weapon you can see the a lot of
Ukrainian refugees this section of the
Rochelle plant is what makes the
operation unique when shimanov needed
experienced welders he tapped into his
Ukrainian connections to find employees
who desperately wanted to contribute to
the war effort shimanov says in total
Rochelle has hired at least 30 newcomers
from Ukraine since the War Began and
that number keeps growing
I have one guy that's worth 20 people
that's true like sometimes we and the
management we stand and we and we gaze
and we don't understand how one person
can do so much
that person is a barrel-chested man
named vlodimir
and don't let the smile fool you he's
got an iron grip
but he says the truly strong people are
the Warriors the heroes they are
fighting and defending the Homeland
we're helping as much as we can but
we're not as strong as they are
shimanov has personal motivation to help
as much as he can too his wife is
Ukrainian and he's also an immigrant he
grew up in Israel and like all Israelis
served in the military and then a decade
ago he sought a fresh start in the west
Canada he says was an easy choice and
that's no question no doubt that Canada
is one of the best places to raise your
kids and to run a business
the extremely focused shimanov had his
first big success in the armored car
industry far too many robberies of cash
transporting vehicles are inside jobs so
he developed technology that removes
control from any one person
and with this system we're basically
able to control the vehicle remotely in
an encrypted way how many of your
armored vehicles have been robbed zero
zero zero not like
one percent zero zero point zero percent
none of our vehicles were robbed cash
transport giant garter worlds has bought
hundreds of Rochelle armored vehicles
since 2020 with plans to eventually
replace its entire North American Fleet
if the success of its armored cash cars
is Rochelle's lifeblood the senator has
become its heart when you see the
deoccupied city and you see all of the
people are coming from the buildings and
they put the Ukrainian flag and you see
that those soldiers are standing on your
vehicle that's something that you know
it's Way Beyond just making money and
that's saying something given that last
year Rochelle taught more than 100
million dollars in Revenue in only its
fifth year among their clients NASA the
U.S state Department various security
agencies in the U.S and Western allies
shimanov insists Rochelle doesn't sell
to individuals or Rogue Nations
[Music]
as Rochelle churns out Senators at
Breakneck Pace the sound of this
Canadian production line
is music to the ears of Ukrainian
soldiers to all camadian people who
support Ukraine please keep doing it
further because we really need to be
ourselves the ukrainians not to be part
of Russia thank you very much
seems the only person who's not a fan is
a certain president the Russians must
not like you though
yeah they don't like me and they don't
like my colleagues and my company
shimanov found out this summer he's been
blacklisted by Vladimir Putin something
he sees as a badge of honor for us is
the best recognition that we could get
and I open a bottle of champagne the day
when I read that I'm in sectionalist I
have another bottle for the day when
Putin will be gone